my name is Grand Master Ben Feingold
that is my middle name obviously and I
wanted to show you a couple of games I
played yesterday fact the tournament
that I'm playing in is going on right
now but instead of playing in the
tournament I'm lecturing to you because
that's more fun okay now this was my
second round game and I had the black
pieces so I got to do some weird stuff
there we go
was that weird okay now in this game we
played my favorite opening and my
favorite pizza so what's that it's my
favorite opening in pizza Sicilian very
good okay
and we got our Knights out now the open
Sicilian is the most common that's with
D for my opponent play D for later he
played it when he felt like it he
developed his bishop so he could castle
or as they say in the previous class
what's castling okay and I played a six
and he castled and then I got my night
out
now who's played bughouse before if you
fight bughouse the correct to move is
for whites to put a knight on d6
checkmate but this isn't bug house this
is real life so my opponent played an
unusual move I've had people play c3 and
rook e1 and Knight c3 and b3 but my
opponent played the sixth most common
move I've never faced that before so I
started crying
he played d4 his pawns are in the center
that's not fair because I'm his opponent
so I took his pawn did he take with a
knight or the Queen
for the one o'clock class that's too
hard
no no Queen sacrifice now okay he took
with a night right okay right who's the
quietest we have a prize for that all
right I play Queen b6 and I got two guys
attacking his night but he saw it and he
played night takes tonight and now I
have so many captures I was confused I
could take this is one capture another
one another one another one and another
one
although the last one's pretty bad I
could also take his pawn after very good
I didn't see that one okay so I took
with a D pawn which is unusual but my
computer likes it
he saved his bishop and I put my pawn in
I put knight g6 so my mission could get
out okay now in this position in my
opinion white should move his Knight to
g2 then he could play Knight c4
attacking my queen but instead he played
nine c3 and now his knight can go
anywhere then my queen can stay here so
I did I play d5 in the center now my
opponent played a mu but he didn't know
why then I told him why he was like oh
yeah so I thought I thought my opponent
wanted to develop his bishop but then he
would lose a pawn so he played the move
a3 pawn to a3 and I thought he was going
to play Bishop e3 next to move and he
was like but what if you take my pawn
and I said then you trap my Queen and he
said oh and the reason it my queen strap
is because he played a3 now I can't play
Queen b4 and I can't play Queen a3 so
what I have taken his pawn and lost my
queen now I would have just played Queen
c7 okay but he didn't play Bishop e3 he
made what's called an ante positional
move it's a move that weakens everything
so if we go to the beginning
does anybody here play beef LAN move one
is Kokomo here right nobody does because
that's a strange move but my opponent
played b4 in this position when it was
also strange okay because now nothing is
protecting the ninth and the white
squares are all weak and so forth okay
so I Castle because that's what I do and
my opponent thought I was going to play
Bishop e6 next to move and the reason he
thought that is because it's true so he
played Bishop c4 he wanted to mess my
pawns up and I was like I want to go
Bishop here but if you take I don't want
to take with my pawn and mess my pawns
up
so I played Knight f4 so my Knights
protecting right in front of the camera
good job all right now my opponent
attacks my queen but I sacrificed my
queen right no no no okay
move my queen he moved his queen and I
played a5 now I'm attacking his pawn
hooray yeah okay now after the game my
opponent was like hmm I played this rook
here defending my pawn should I have
played the other rook the answer is no
if he plays the other rook now this rook
is overworked after we trade pawns I can
trade rooks and now there's no rukon his
pawn so free pawn so he actually played
the right move he defended with his
other rug and we traded pawns and now I
started thinking I was thinking and
thinking and thinking that my head
started to hurt I was thinking if I
attack his knight
see how it's attacked he'll take my
knight defending his Knight I'll take
his Bishop and now he'll play the
craziest move ever like a knight here
attacking my queen so forth attacking my
rock
I was getting confused okay so instead I
played b5 attacking his bishop but he
saw it and then I thought about it again
but I was getting confused again because
this is attacked and this is attacked
this is attacked and I was like ah okay
so I had to do that
I played Bishop e6 now black has an
advantage here first of all this is all
the same right to bishops okay so what
are the differences my works on an open
line his rooks not so good my Knights
all up in his grill and his knight can't
move his knight can't move to any of
these squares because he'll just lose
his knight okay and they can't go here
or here because there's pieces there so
his knight can't really move and my
Knights gray my rook is awesome and this
pawn I can attack which I did this pawn
is defended by a pond so black has a lot
of advantages okay he played rook e1 and
I played Bishop d6 when I play Bishop d6
after the game he said why did you play
Bishop d6 and the reason I played it he
stopped by accident
why did my opponents made good moves by
accident I wanted to play Queen e7 and
my Queen and Bishop attack his pawn and
there's no defense he can't defend his
pawn but he actually defended his pawn
anyway without seeing my threat he
played 91 and now if I attack his pawn
he can play c3 and defend his pawn
wasn't that lucky of him okay so I
played rook to a2 attacking his pawn but
he saw it okay then I played f5 hooray
and now I'm winning because I got
everything attacking him here and here
in here and his pieces are all trapped
they can't move Knights on d1 anyway
there's a saying in chess you want your
rook on the seventh rank because then
your rook is attacking everything my
rook saan the
seventh rank such attacking everything
he didn't like my rook on the seventh
rank so he called over the director and
Mike comer was the director and he was
like no rooks on the seventh rank okay
so he played rook to be - so we could
trade rooks also on his Barney chess I
take you you take me
you're the worst player in history okay
but I didn't take his rook I took his
pawn who's the quietest right now you
see I took his pawn did he take my rook
now because then he'd be the worst
player I take his queen okay
so he took with the Queen and I took his
rook and now he played a crazy move some
would say Matt Barrett is crazy nice
like to get that in there after the move
rook takes rook what would you play with
ye
yeah sorry you would take it with a
knight like everybody else in the world
right he didn't do that yay he's my
student okay
so he knew if he took with the rook he
was losing so he played a different
losing move that lost even more heat a
so the rook I have two ways to win I was
going to play Bishop f5 where does the
Queen go to safety one safe Square
Martin f3 then II four where does the
Queen go to safety Martin Queen G 3 now
Knight takes check and Bishop takes
Queen so that wasn't too safe was it
that's what I was going to play the
computer wants me to play Bishop d5 and
says it's even better and then attack
over here okay either way is good
so my opponent played Bishop takes
Knight instead of taking my rook I
played rook takes Bishop now if you're
good at counting and you're not if you
were you would notice black is up a ruck
and for nothing not even a pun nothing I
got an extra room okay so he thought
he'll get two rooks you know for his
queen so he took that rook and then he
was going to take this rook but I played
rook takes Bishop now I'm threatening
well let's have a look I'm threatening
rook takes rook me that's a good move
and I'm threatening pawn takes Queen and
now he did what any good player would do
yeah he gave up he could the best he
could do is take my rock and take or I
could blunder that take his queen and
then I have a queen for a rock that is
nice that's so good okay so instead he
gave up he could claim the draw but that
doesn't work that only works with your
friends okay all right so I won hooray
then I had to play the infamous James
McLaughlin how does it set up good okay
I've I have to flip the board that was
the game I played last night okay and
today I'm taking byes because I'm
teaching these classes so I had to win
this game if I want to win any prize
money and I do want to win prize money
okay so I was why am i opponent rated
2100 but before you were born he was
rated 2,300 okay his rating went down
all right so I'm why
and we played your favorite opening the
nimzo-indian named after which Grand
Master that was his name nimzo-indian in
a funny name now okay his name is aron
nimzowitsch okay we could look him up on
the internet but that would waste
valuable seconds okay nimzowitsch wrote
a very famous book let's see if Ben
Simon knows the title very good he
pulled out of the back of his head
somewhere
yeah it's called my system if you can't
sleep one night you have insomnia you
could read that you fall right to sleep
Pam you'll be like I couldn't sleep last
night
nothing worked I counted sheep I counted
rooks then if you read my system you
fall right asleep okay well it's not the
most exciting book it's a chess book
explaining his ideas and you're like ah
okay
so I played Queen c2 because that's what
I do now when I was your age except
older about 1415 I had a t-shirt that it
said Queen c2 exclamation point okay
because I like to play Queen c2 here
okay my opponent played e5 and we traded
pawns and I played Bishop g5 and he
attacked my bishop now you can take the
knight or go back I've done both but not
at the same time I retreated
he played c5 and I took it now he made a
very unusual move if you look at a chess
database there'll be about a thousand
games in this position with Garry
Kasparov having white in several of them
and everybody plays g5 attacking the
bishop my opponent played Bishop e6 I
didn't know that move so I was confused
okay where did I move my bishop nowhere
so I played III now I can move it
somewhere he played ninety seven I
pinned his knight now both of his
Knights are pinned let's see who the
smartest is what kind of pin is that and
what kind of pin is that right relative
is the green one absolute is the red one
absolute means the computer won't let me
move it because it's illegal relative
means it'll let me move it and then you
lose your queen sort of like what I'm
playing you kids okay so now my opponent
thought forever and he played g5 thought
about ten minutes I would say I move my
bishop and now he played a very sneaky
move remember how this is an absolute
pin this is also an absolute pin so he
played Queen a5 and if I go do let's
develop some pieces then I lose a bishop
for nothing because my Knights pinned
also he would call the director and the
director had saying what's the problem
and he would say my opponent going did
it to do that actually that's based on a
true story
yeah my son was the was a director of a
kid's tournament like you kids and they
were like 500 of them
so like 500 times worse than you and
then kids raised their hand when they
want a director and my son came over and
said yeah and he said my opponent keeps
going
that was his complaint yeah
yeah my son's like what okay
so yeah when onigiri is playing MV Ali's
like my opponent is making French noises
okay so now I save my bishop Bishop
takes Knight and he took back and I
played ninety two rook c8 I castled and
he took my knight and he took my pawn
okay this is the first interesting
position if you count everything you'll
notice we have the same things we both
have a king we both have a queen we both
have two rooks we both have a bishop in
the night and we both have six pawns
fortunately my pawns are awesome my
pawns are all together my king is safe
his pawns it looks like he's playing an
accordion over here he's got a lot of
holes in the position he's got no
control the dark squares even they play
g5 and this pawn is weak as it has a
name isolated so he has a lot of
problems and some of them are chess
problem now if it was his turn to move
he would play Knight e4 and my Knights
attacked four hundred times and pinned
so I played Queen d2 there's a very
tricky move
he plays ninety four now that would be a
blunder I would take it he takes back I
win his queen if he doesn't take back
and takes my queen I take back and I'm
up a free night so did he play Knight e4
and lose the knight now he thought
forever and played queen
to be four okay now he could play 94
next move because his queen protects it
I played Bishop e5 attacking his rook
and he made a move that will surprise
you because you'll be surprised that
it's legal this is the Knights class
still 14-7 okay good what move did he
make that looks illegal but it's not it
looks illegal I'll give you a hint
I've already done it he castles even
though his rooks attack you castled
confusing some of the kids okay I didn't
show this game with a one o'clock kids
because they would just be on the floor
crying they would be like the rook was
attack he can't castle then they start
crying okay alright and now if I don't
make a move let's make a random move he
plays 94 I take and he takes to the
Queen so I stopped all that I played
Bishop to d4 now if he plays 94 he can't
take it with the Queen because he can't
jump over my bishop so he just loses a
night then so he played Knight a four
and now I thought forever
I thought about 10 minutes here and I
played rook to d1 defending my Queen and
we traded Knights and now I want to play
Queen d4 and checkmate
Rey but he played Queenie for my play
Queen d4 helps take it I played f3 and
he must have thought he was mvl because
he were treated like a Frenchman so
queen h7 and now that's a very silly
queen but it makes it really hard for me
to checkmate him okay so Queen d4 am i
threatening mate no but I'm threading
this pawn over here so he defended it
and I put my Queen in here and he didn't
like my Queen in there he's like man
that Queens in there he attacks my queen
I'll check made him so he didn't do that
he played rook c6 to kick out my queen
and he kicked out my queen
then I attacked his pawn and then I did
a spoon I mean a knife I mean chopsticks
I mean what do I mean a fork
I played Queen a for forking his rook
and his pawn
is anybody smart enough to defend both
of them how do you save them both in the
corner you're also in the corner he's
more in the corner you threw your voice
good right and that's what he did
then I attacked his rook again with my
bishop even saved his rook and then
there's this nice open sea foul nobody
has except I have it now rook c1 so my
bishops better than his my Queens better
than his I have the dominating rook his
king is open and he has an isolated pawn
so White's better okay rook c1 of course
he attacked my bishop but I saw it that
I doubled on the open file
hooray for me and then I went to attack
hooray and he played g4 he couldn't take
it anymore okay then I took 2f file yay
okay now I played a5 and traded pawns he
has four isolated pawns the world's
record okay and also my bishop is
beautiful in the center and also his
King has a lot of open space in front of
it my king is pretty safe also my rooks
are Don this week pawn and his rook is
defending the pawn so White has a
thousand advantages okay I played rook
f4 so this pawn could never move and
then I played took the file again he
attacked my queen I attacked his pawn
again sure he defended it and now that
his bishop and queen are defending his
pawn he blocked his rook so my rook was
like thank you very much and he attacks
my rook but I saw it okay now the
computer said this is the only move of
the game it didn't like the computer
wants me to sacrifice all my pieces
computers okay so I played rook a seven
and I won the game in one more move so
it must be okay but the computers like
why didn't you take this pawn let's
let's analyze okay he can take either
one of my rooks right but I win if he
does either one takes this rook I go
check if he trades rooks that's
checkmate
and if he doesn't trade rooks then I'm
threatening Queen takes pawn mate and
Queen f7 mate and rook g7 is going to be
me and I'm up upon so it doesn't like
this for him question then he's down a
queen okay the other move he can play
the other movie can play is Bishop takes
this rook
now I take with check what does he do he
has to go back to g8 now the computer
wants me to take this rook I think and
then take this with check and then it
says I'm winning but I'm not going to do
this that's crazy so instead I won even
quicker by playing a worse move I played
rook a seven and now he blundered
because he had 30 seconds on his clock
and I had about an hour because I was
trying to watch this football game I'm
not sure why so notice notice all my
pieces are good and my king is safe and
all his pieces are bad his King's not
safe especially his bishop my bishop is
really good his bishop is like trapped
behind his pawns
so usually not always when somebody's
crushing you and they're dominating and
they're all up in your grille you want
to try
eight pieces then if there's no pieces
on the board they won't beat you so he
was like man this work on the seven
that's annoying okay just like my last
rook on the seventh against Matt Barrett
so he played Bishop e6 and he wanted to
trade rooks he's like rook takes rook
Queen takes truck or Bishop f7 Queen
takes Rock or we could start over or we
could go in fast motion okay you have to
wave your hand to do that okay yeah all
right
so in this position that wasn't as fast
as I thought okay so after rook a7
he played Bishop to e6 okay
now this should be six is the losing
move because he's overworked okay so his
queen is defending his rook as we saw in
the previous variation if only his Queen
wasn't defending his rock then I could
take his rook for free he how could I do
that how can i how can i how can I raise
my hand you incorrect you yeah give me
the move even with this pawn here you
mean no
that is pawn would take and I would cry
you with an on crying answer incorrect
we're right that's just--that's to
tactics in one you got to pay double
Bishop e5 that's getting his queen off
of his rock you know decoy deflection
and it's a skewer so actually if he
wants to he can save his rook he can
move his queen here but then he loses
that rook
so I'm attacking both of his rooks and
his queen now in this position if I play
Bishop e5 he can take with his queen but
he played Bishop e6 so now if he takes
for this Queen his rooks not defended so
Bishop e6 was a mistake which was
punished by Bishop e5 and now he did
what any chess master would do yeah he
gave up the correct move is to take I
take check and the computer says I'm +7
that means the computer likes white
because +7 is like seven puns up because
yeah so I'm sort of like the RAM 21-7
yeah this would be white winning 21 7 so
that was the game that I played last
night and then I took by still teach you
and he played this morning and he
crushed his opponent see how much he
learned from this game right so even
though he lost he learned a lot so he
was happy he lost right yeah yeah now he
didn't cry that much he waited till I
got home to cry yeah he held it in good
yeah all right so those are my games
yesterday and I was fortuitous that
means lucky especially if you see
tombstone right now you're too young for
that joke
you